learn more about the web authentication
API by building an app that implements
Pass Key authentication the web
authentication API lets you create and
use origin scoped public key credentials
to authenticate users at the end of this
course you will have an expressjs app
connected to a postrest database inside
a Docker
container hello and welcome to this div
Rhino video here on the free code cam
channel so glad to see you in this
tutorial we will learn more about the
web authentication API by building an
expressjs app that implements Pass Key
authentication to follow along you will
need to have Docker installed and
running you can head over to their
website to find the version that suits
your environment even though we're using
no JS in this tutorial you do not have
to have it installed on your machine
this tutorial will focus on the key
Concepts involved in the implementation
of of a public key pair credential
system it does not dive into security
any robust error handling data
validation or any other authentication
Edge Case by the end of the tutorial we
will have created an app that will allow
the user to register and create a pass
key with an authenticator of their
choice they will also be able to log out
and log back in with their brand new
Pass Key now let's get started we can
begin by creating a new folder for our
project and immediately changing into it
then we will create the config files
we'll need to work with Docker we'll
create a Docker file a Docker composed.
yaml file and a Docker ignore file now
let's open up the docker file to add an
instruction to pull the official node.js
image for version 19 we will also add an
instruction to set the path to the
working directory over in the docker
composed. yaml file we will set the
version to 3.8 then we will create our
first service for our web server it will
use port 3000 and persist data in a
volume in the dot Docker ignore file we
will want to ignore node modules and any
npm debugging logs that's the minimal
config we need to get started we can now
run the docker compose up command to
create our new container now we can
verify that node.js was successfully
installed by entering our web container
and checking for the version if you see
a similar print out you're good to go
while we're still in the web container
Shell let's initialize our project to
use npm then we can install the Express
package as a dependency now we can
create a new index.js file to act as the
entry point to our application then we
can head to the expressjs documentation
and copy over the example web server
starter code we'll update the port
constant to to use an environment
variable and also set the host variable
to listen to any available network
interface now we can start up our web
server by running the node index.js
command if we open up Local Host Port
3000 in our browser we should see the
hello world text let's head back to our
web server code and say hello to the
universe instead if we go and refresh
our browser now our changes are not
reflected our app has no way of
rebuilding on the Fly yet to introduce
this Behavior we can install the node
Monon package as a Dev dependency now
with this package we can start our web
server by using the node mon command
instead if we head to our browser now
our changes are reflected upon refresh
but what happens if we delete our node
modules folder perhaps a teammate has
cloned the repository and has not
install the dependencies if they try to
run the web server they will see a
message about missing packages
they could always just reinstall them
but this is kind of sad let's improve
the developer experience by updating our
Docker file with an instruction to copy
over the package.json files then we can
add another instruction to install
dependencies so now whenever a new Dev
spins up this project they have all the
dependencies they need we will also head
over to the docker compost. yaml file
and add a volume to persist the node
modules between builds we should also
add the startup command here too so that
it maps to the docker compose up command
now we can exit the web container and
rebuild our app we can restart our app
using the docker compose up command if
we head into our browser nothing has
visually changed however our app is
still functioning as expected which is a
good sign to round this section out we
will add some final touches to our
Docker file we can add a line for the
starting command then we can add another
instruction that copies all the project
files from the host into the Container
these instructions won't make a
difference for our local setup but they
will be useful if we ever deploy our app
to a service that doesn't support Docker
compose this section is over and you're
doing great let's keep going in this
section we will set SQ eyes up as our om
while our app is still running we can
open a different terminal Tab and
install the SQL IED package then we can
also install the SQL CLI package as a
Dev dependency once that is installed we
can initialize sqy for our project using
the CLI tool this command will create
all the files we need however they are
not in the locations that we'd like to
have them in so let's do some
housekeeping let's create a couple of
new directories called app and DB then
let's move the models directory into the
new app directory we'll move the
migrations folder into DB and the SE
this folder into the DB folder as well
then we will rename the config.js file
to database. JS now we will open up the
models index file and make sure our
config is pointing to the correct file
we've made quite a few changes but squiz
expects the files it generates to be
found in specific locations so we need
to create a sqy RC config file to
overwrite the default paths that SQL
eyes expects finally we need to update
our database config file we'll convert
the Json to JavaScript and store it in a
constant called DB settings which we
will export we need to convert this file
from Json to JavaScript so we can access
environment variables we also change the
dialect from MySQL to postgressql by
default SQL users
MySQL let's set up a postgress database
for our application we've already
started using using environment
variables in our code but we haven't
actually defined them yet so let's
create a EnV file to store them the PG
host will point to the database
container that we will create shortly PG
Port will be set to the default port for
postgress PG user will be the name of
the user that will connect to the
database PG password will be the
password and PG database will be set to
the name we will give our database once
our variables are defined we can head
into the docker composed. yaml file and
tell our web service to pull them in now
we can set up a new service for our
postgress database we will not set up
our own Docker file for this service and
instead we will use an official
postgress image we will also use the
environment variables from the EnV file
to set up our database the port will use
the default postgress port and we will
set up a named volume to persist our
database between builds lastly we will
set the web service to depend on this
new DB service now let's build our
database container we can kill the
server and rebuild the app then we can
start it up again we will access the
shell of the new DB container and use
psql to connect to our database using
the credentials we have stored in ourv
file if you see a similar output your
database has been set up we can also use
a database client to connect to our
database we can use the same credentials
from ourv file here as well our database
is currently empty while we have seen
how we can connect to the database
manually we should also give our web
server a way to connect programmatically
let's head back into the terminal and
install the postgress package then we
can create a helpers folder in our DB
directory here we will create a little
file file that will allow our code to
access the database this file will
define an export a module called DB this
module will use sqy to create a new
database connection using the variables
located in ourv file we will also set
the dialect to postgressql now that our
app can use sqy to connect to the
database let's generate our first sqz
model this will correspond to a database
table we will run the model generate
command to create a user model we will
give it a name and a single attribute
for email this command will generate a
new model file and an accompanying
migration file let's open up our user
model file and add some more attributes
we can see that our email attribute
already exists which is expected now
let's improve it until tell sqe that it
should be unique we can now add a new
handle attribute and the usual timestamp
column
we want to follow a different convention
for the table names so let's also
provide a new table name setting we can
head over to our migration file and
update the table names in there as well
let's also tell the migration that we
need the email to be unique we can add
the handle attribute here as well now we
have enough to migrate the database we
can use the sqz CLI tool to perform the
migration once the command executes we
can see that the settings in our
migration file have been applied if we
open up our database client we can see a
new users table that contains all the
columns we
configured let's set up a dedicated
routes file and our first controller in
our terminal let's create a new file to
organize our routes within this new
routes file we will import the Express
package so that we can create a new
router now that we have a dedicated
routes file we no longer need to to put
our routes in the index.js file let's
cut our only route from
index.js and paste it into the routes
file and then let's import and use our
routes file within
index.js now let's create a new folder
for our controllers within the
controllers folder we can create a new
pages controller introducing controllers
will allow us to further clean up our
route handlers inside the pages
controller let's add a new action called
welcome the new welcome action is a call
back Handler that we will pass to our
routes it takes a request a response and
the next call back is its arguments
within its body it will check for a user
if there is no user it will render a
welcome message if there is a user it
will call the next function on the stack
if this pattern looks familiar it's
because this is just a regular old
middleware function that is commonly
seen in nextjs apps now we can head back
into our routes file and clean it up a
little further we will import the pages
controller and set up the root route so
that it calls the welcome action from
the pages controller and with that we
now have the concept of routes and
controllers within our app now let's
configure our app for front-end views
and static assets we will be using the
ejs and express ejs layout packages so
we can hop into the terminal and install
them then we can head into the index.js
file to configure them we will tell our
app to use layouts and we will set the
path to where all our View files will
live then we will set our default layout
file and also set our view engine to use
ejs we are using the path package so we
should import it now that our app is
configured to handle views let's create
a folder for them we will start working
on the global application layout first
so let's create a folder and a file for
it we can open up the application layout
file and add some boilerplate HTML
markup to it there isn't much happening
here we've just given it a title and
specified that it should be responsive
the only interesting part is this
template string this is the bit that
will pull the body content from our
individual View files now we can create
our first Real Page since we've already
got a welcome controller action it only
makes sense to create a new welcome view
we will head to the project repository
and copy over the markup for our new
welcome page HTML is out of scope for
this tutorial so we will not go over
this but please feel free to dive into
it on your own if you're interested now
that we have a proper welcome page we
can head into the pages controller and
update the action to render it if we
head into the browser now we can see the
content we added for the welcome page
now now let's work on giving our views
some Styles back in the terminal we can
create a new CSS file in the public
folder then we will head into the
project repo and copy over the readymade
CSS CSS is also out of scope for this
video so we will not be explaining any
of the Styles once we save the file and
head into the browser we see that
nothing happened that's because our app
knows nothing about this new stylesheet
we added so first we can head into our
application layout file and import our
stylesheet then we can open up the
index.js file and configure our app to
look for static Assets in the public
folder now when we go back to our
browser and refresh we should see our
Styles coming through but our logo is
broken let's go back to the project
repository and download the images
folder then we can drag it into our
local public folder inside we have three
custom cursor images and a couple of
different logos if we head back into our
browser now our logo image should now be
showing up now let's create a page that
will hold our registration form if we
head into the browser now and click on
the register button we're met with an
error saying the register route does not
exist well this makes sense because we
haven't created a register route yet
let's open up our routes file and get to
work we are importing the O controller
that doesn't exist yet then we add a new
get route Handler that calls an action
called register which will live in the O
controller that we will create now we
can open up the new Au controller and
add the register action which will
render the register view then we will
head into the project repo and copy over
the markup for the register view if we
refresh our browser now our register
page should be rendering correctly now
let's create a page for our login form
then we can add a route Handler for the
login route and inside our off
controller we can add a login action
that will render the login page then we
can head into the project repo and copy
over the markup for this login page once
that is saved we can head back into the
browser and check it out it looks very
similar to the register page but this is
the login form now let's set up the
final page which will be the dashboard
let's add a new view file for it and we
will update the root route to take a
second action then we can create a new
admin controller and add a dashboard
action which will render the dashboard
page this dashboard action is the one we
referenced back in the routes file now
let's get the markup for the dashboard
and paste it into the view file we will
not view the dashboard page in the
browser for now it can be a nice little
surprise once we start implementing pass
Keys we've made it to another Milestone
we've covered a lot and you've been
phenomenal let's create a model and
migration for the public key credentials
we already have a users table now we
need a public key credentials table to
store the public keys for each user we
will use the model generate command from
the SQ CLI tool giving it a model name
and a single attribute which is the
public key string this command will
generate a model file and an
accompanying migration file we can open
up the public key credentials model and
add a coup couple more attributes for
username and external ID these columns
will help us identify public keys and
Associate them to specific users and
since we're following a different
convention for table names let's also
configure the table name setting too we
will add a belongs to Association
because a public key should belong to a
user record through the user ID now
let's open up the migration file and add
the same attributes here as well then we
must also remember to update the table
name to match the new table name we set
in the model file we've already stated
that public key records belong to users
so we should head into the users model
and indicate that a user has many public
key credentials now we can migrate the
database so that our new changes can be
applied if we open up our database
client we can see a brand new table
called public key credentials our
database is all set now now let's let's
configure passportjs to handle
authentication we will be creating a
service to organize our passportjs
related code let's first install the
base passport package then we can
install the passport web Oren strategy
package this will give us the ability to
authenticate with pass Keys now we can
create a new file for a service in the
services directory we will set up the
module with an init method that contains
the three main functions we need to
implement now we can head into our
routes file and import our newly created
passport service we will also import the
session challenge store from the web
Oran strategy package because we will
need this to generate challenges then we
can create a new instance of the
passport service and a new instance of
the session challenge store then we can
initialize the passport service instance
and pass the challenge store to it back
in our passport service file the first
thing we need to do is configure
passport to use the web orth strategy
the passport use method accepts a call
back we have created one that we have
called use web auen strategy within the
function body we will return a new web
Oren strategy instance which takes three
pieces of information first we will pass
in the challenge store in an object then
we will pass in a verify call back and a
register call back we should should also
remember to import the passport and web
Oren strategy packages at the top of the
file since we are using them the verify
call back will be used when a user logs
in and the register call back will be
used when a user registers a new account
neither of these callbacks exist yet so
we will need to create them we can start
with the verify call back the end goal
of this function is to look up a
specified user in the database and get
their public key it will will be an
async function that takes in an ID user
handle and a done call back we've made
it an async function because it will be
interacting with our database within the
body of the function we will create a
database transaction if anything were to
go wrong the database transaction will
allow us to roll back our actions
without persisting the changes to the
database we're using the DB helper so we
should remember to import it at the top
of the file back in the function body we
will use a TR catch statement if the
actions within the tri block are
successful we will commit the
transaction however if we get an error
we will drop into the catch block and
roll back the transaction now let's put
together our database interactions back
in the tri block we will use sqz defined
one public key credentials record from
the database where the external ID
matches the ID value we passed into the
verify function we must also remember to
pass in the transaction because we want
this action to be wrapped in a database
transaction we're using the models
object here so we should import it at
the top of the file for some basic error
handling we will send back an error
message if we cannot find the public key
credentials now let's try to find the
specific user that owns the public key
credential we will also remember to pass
the transaction to this action as well
because we want to to be wrapped within
the same database transaction as our
first action if we are unable to find
the user we will send an error message
saying as much we will also add another
check to ensure that the user handle we
passed in matches the user handle for
the user we retrieved from the database
if all these actions are successful we
will commit the transaction and execute
the done call back with the credentials
record and public key and now our verify
function is complete
we can collapse it and work on the
register call back the end goal of this
function is to create a new user and a
new Associated public key credentials
record and persist them in the database
it will be an async function that takes
in a user ID public key and a done call
back within the body of the function we
will create a database transaction if
anything were to go wrong the database
transaction will allow us to roll back
our changes without persisting any data
to the database we will use a TR catch
statement if the actions within the tri
block are successful we will commit the
transaction however if we get an error
we will drop into the catch block and
roll back the transaction now let's put
together our database interactions in
the tri block we will attempt to create
a new user record in the database using
values from the user object we passed
into the register function we will also
remember remember to pass the
transaction to this database interaction
because we want to be able to roll it
back if anything goes wrong for some
basic error handling if we are unable to
create a new user record we will send
back an error message next we will try
to create a new public key credentials
record to associate with our new user
record again we are passing in the
transaction because we want this action
to be wrapped within the same database
transaction as our user cre creation
action if we are unable to create new
credentials we will send back an error
message if the actions within the tri
block are successful we will commit the
transaction but if we get an error we
will drop into the catch block and roll
back the action now that the register
function is also complete we can
collapse it and move on looking back at
our notes the next task we need to work
on is to serialize the user to a token
serialization involves taking in a
regular JavaScript object containing
user details and converting that into an
encrypted string which is also known as
a token to achieve this we will use the
serialized user method from the passport
package the serialized user method takes
a call back so we will create a little
call back function to pass to it we will
just name it serialized user function
because naming is difficult when this
call back function is executed it will
call nodes process process next tick
function which will invoke the done
function with the JavaScript object
containing user details process next
tick is a node.js thing and is a little
out of scope for our current tutorial
the last thing we need for this passport
service is the ability to deserialize a
user deserialization involves reading
and extracting user information from a
token we can use passports deserialized
user method here and pass it a little
call back function that we will call
deserialize user function this is very
similar to the serialize user function
but we sent through the whole user
object the web Oren API requires session
support so let's set that up we can kick
things off by installing the express
session package we can also install the
connect session SQL package so we can
use sqy to store session data to our
database now we we can head into the
index JS file and import the passport
package the express session package and
the connect session sqz package we
should also import the DB helper since
we will be storing session data in the
database now we can create a new
instance of a session store and
configure it to use our existing
database we will now configure out app
to use the session we've set the secret
to an environment variable that doesn't
exist yet so we will come back to it
we've also made sure to tell our app to
use the session store we created above
and we've indicated that we'd like the
cookies to expire after 1 week in a real
production system this is the place we
would also add more security related
settings finally we will sync our
session store and also configure our app
to use passport to authenticate with
sessions now let's go back and add the
session secret variable to ourv file
we're just using some random string in
order to see our changes take effect we
need to restart our server that has been
running in a different terminal tab if
we visit our database client now we
should see a new sessions table this is
automatically generated for us if you
are having trouble seeing the same
results you may need to head into the
browser and do a quick refresh now our
app supports sessions
while we're in a configuration mood
let's head back into index.js and add a
few more helpful settings we need our
app to be able to work with Json so
let's configure it to use the buil-in
express. Json function we will also
install and configure a package called
malter so we can submit multi-art form
data then we will also install and
configure the cookie passer package so
that our app knows how to pass cookies
finally we should also configure our app
to handle any URLs that contain query
pram data we are now ready to take a
high Lev look at how pass Keys work
public key cryptography Is Not A New
Concept if you are familiar with RSA
private and public Keys these ideas may
feel Vaguely Familiar to you however
pass keys are making the concept more
mainstream with the goal of replacing
password
authentication pass keys are used in two
different phases es the first phase is
the attestation phase where the pass key
is created during the user registration
process the second phase is the
assertion phase where the users's
credentials are verified allowing them
to log in during these two phases there
are three main entities involved first
is the authenticator which could be a
smartphone a password manager or a USB
device next is the client an example of
which could be a user interacting with
their browser
and finally the relying party which
could be your own server or the server
of another application that supports
pass keys in the upcoming sections we
will implement the two different
phases let's Implement phase one where a
pass key is created upon user
registration before we dive into the
code let's go over a quick summary of
the main things that happened between
the client the authenticator and the
relying party first the user submits the
the registration form prompting the
client to request a challenge from the
relying party secondly the client calls
the Navigator do credentials. create
method this will prompt the
authenticator to use the challenge it
receives to create a new credential key
pair the authenticator will pop up a
dialogue asking the user for
verification in our case this
verification will be done through a
fingerprint once the user is verified
the private key is stored on the
authenticator and used to sign the
challenge then the public key the sign
Challenge and the credential ID are sent
back to the client finally the client
sends the public key the sign Challenge
and the credential ID to the relying
party the server verifies the sign
challenge using the public key and the
session information it receives if the
verification process is successful the
server will store the public key
credentials and user details in the
database
now that we have an idea of the flow we
want to achieve let's start working on
the code inside our code editor let's
find our bearings by taking a look
inside the register View at the very
bottom of the file we have imported two
script files however neither of them
exist yet so we will need to create them
first we will create the attestation
register script file then we will create
the base 64 URL script file we will head
into the project Repository story and
copy over the contents for the base 64
URL script the original GitHub link for
this little utility helper can be found
at the top of the file so you can get
the code from the original project as
well this base 64 URL script will ensure
that binary data and URLs are properly
encoded to plain text to avoid ambiguity
once we've saved the file we can start
working on our attestation register
module we will create a new register
class that contains an init function we
have left some notes to guide us the
first three steps correspond to the
steps we saw in the section overview the
fourth step is Just a ux Touch where we
redirect the user to the dashboard at
the bottom of the file we will listen
for the window object to load once the
window has loaded we will add an event
listener to the registration form so
whenever it is submitted we will create
a new instance of our register CL class
and call the init function we will also
prevent the default behavior that the
browser gives to the form element our
first function will allow the client to
request a challenge from the server it
will be an async function that we will
call get challenge in the body of this
get challenge function we will make a
request to this endpoint that doesn't
exist yet it will be a post request and
we will send through the data a user
submits through the registration form
then at the end of the function we will
return the Json response now let's go
and add this register public key
challenge endpoint to the routes file
we're adding a new post route Handler
that calls the create Challenge from
function from the off controller this
action doesn't exist yet so we can head
into the off controller and add it
within the body of this action we will
return a middleware function inside this
middleware function body we will set up
a user object we will set its ID to a uu
ID value we generate the name will be
derived from the email address the user
sends through in the registration form
we will also remember to import The UU
ID package at the top of the file we
haven't installed it yet but we will
install it shortly we will then use the
challenge method from The Challenge
store to set up yep you guessed it a
challenge the user object and the
challenge will be returned in the Json
response we have used the base 64 URL
package to encode our user ID and
challenge we also use this on the front
end but this is the back end so it needs
its own copy of the package while we're
here we will also install The UU ID
package from earlier we should also
remember to import the base 64 URL
package before we move on now we can
head back to our attestation register
script and work on the Second Step this
is the step where the client will prompt
the authenticator to use the challenge
to generate a new credential key pair it
will be an async function that will
receive a challenge then it will use the
Navigator credentials create function to
create a new credential key pair this
Navigator credentials create function is
part of the web authentication API from
JavaScript at the end of the function we
will return the newly created
credentials you may have noticed that we
passed in some options that don't don't
exist yet so we will need to create them
the first key we set up in the options
object needs to be public key because
this is the type of credential we are
looking to create we will also set the
name of the relying party and then we
will set up a user object containing the
user details next we will set the sign
challenge we got from the previous step
and finally we will set up an array of
encrypted credentials the relying party
will accept each of these correspond on
to a cosos cryptographic algorithm and
are ordered with the most preferred
algorithm at the top of the list finally
we will add an authenticator selection
that prefers user verification that's
all we need for the Second Step let's
collapse the function and move on to our
third step this step will send the
credentials to the server for
verification and return the
authenticated user we will create an
async function that takes in user
credentials this request will also
require us to send through some options
but we will build those in a separate
function shortly we will use the fetch
API to send a request to the login
public key endpoint that does not exist
yet this request will be a post request
and we will pass along the options
object which we have yet to create then
we will return the response now onto the
options we'll set up a new function to
build these the response field will
contain some details about the client
data Json and the attestation object we
will also check if the authenticator
supports different types of transports
transports can include things like
Bluetooth USB or smartphone desktop
hybrids to name a few a full list of
options are available in the
documentation if the authenticator has
transports we will set those in the
options too now let's work on the login
public key endpoint we will head into
the routes file and add a new new post
route Handler this Handler has three
actions configured when working with
expressjs we are able to move through a
stack of middleware so in this case we
will first use passport to perform a
check to see if the user is
authenticated correctly if they are we
will grant them admission into the
application if the check indicates the
user is not authenticated then we will
drop into the last middleware function
in this list and deny them entry this is
very similar to border control at an
airport none of these actions exist yet
so we can head into the off controller
to create them at the very top of the
controller we will set up our passport
check this function will be using the
authenticate method from passport so we
will remember to import passport at the
top of the file the authenticator method
takes in the strategy and an options
object we are using the webo and
strategy and setting up a couple of
options that are related to error
messages now we will work on admitting
an authenticated user if they are
eligible for entry we will set their
destination to the roote route this will
bring them to the dashboard then we can
add the deny user function we will first
check the status code to ensure that it
is not a 400 code so we can return early
but if we do get a 400 code and the user
is not found then we will indicate
everything is not okay and redirect the
unauthenticated user to the Lo login
page this is all we need to authenticate
a user the final step we need to
complete the registration process is to
redirect the user to the appropriate
page our redirect function is pretty
straightforward we will just set the
window location's href value to the
destination we set when checking the
user's passport our registration flow is
now complete so let's head into the
browser to test it out we will use our
cool email address to sign up the client
will then prompt the authenticated to
seek verification from us there are
different options available to us these
options relate to the transports we set
in our options earlier if a user is on a
Mac they can opt to use the built-in
keychain they can also choose to
authenticate using a QR code which they
can scan on their smartphone but for
Simplicity we will use our Chrome
profile however all other methods will
work too one once we hit continue we
will be asked to scan our fingerprint
and because our passport check was
successful we can now see our empty
dashboard we covered a lot of ground but
our registration is done thanks for
persevering you're doing a great job now
let's add the ability for a user to log
out in our browser we can see that we
already have a log out button but if we
click it now the world will end we need
to head back into our code and wire
things up first we will start in our
routes file and add a new post route
Handler for the logout route which will
call the logout action which doesn't
exist yet so we can hop over to our off
controller to add it the logout action
will be a middleware function which will
use the log out method from the request
to log the user out and redirect them to
the root route you may be surprised but
this is all we need now if we head back
to the browser we can safely click on
the button to log our user out
let's Implement phase two where a pass
key is used to authenticate a user and
sign them in before we start writing the
code let's see a quick summary of the
main things that happen between the
client the authenticator and the relying
party in this phase first the user
submits the signin form prompting the
client to request a new random Challenge
from the relying party this first step
is more or less the same as the first
step of the attestation f
secondly the client calls the Navigator
credentials get method this will prompt
the authenticator to request
verification from the user in our case
the verification will be done through a
fingerprint once the user is verified
the authenticator will use the private
key it had previously stored to sign the
challenge then it will send the sign
challenge the credential ID and the
username back to the client the client
then sends this data onwards to the
relying party the server verifies the
sign challenge with the public key it
previously stored in the database if the
verification is successful the server
will find the correct user in the
database and log them into our
application now that we have an idea of
the flow we want to achieve let's get to
work on the code inside our code editor
let's Orient ourselves by looking in the
login View at the very bottom of the
file we have imported two script files
we handled the base 64 URL script in
Phase 1 but the assertion login script
file does not exist yet so let's create
it now we can open up our newly created
file and add a new login class that
contains an innit function we have left
some notes to guide us in the first step
we will check to see if our browser
supports conditional mediation for
public key credentials the middle three
steps correspond to steps we saw in the
phase 2 overview and the last step is a
redirect function that works exactly the
same as the redirect function we
implemented in the registration phase at
the bottom of the file we will listen
for the window object to load we will
then create a new login instance and if
the browser supports pass Keys we will
initialize our new login instance as a
first step we will check if the browser
supports conditional mediation for pass
keys if the browser does not support
this we will return early this
conditional mediation will allow the
browser to find any available pass keys
and display them to the user in a
dialogue box if the browser does not
support this it will not be able to find
the available pass keys this will
prevent the login process from
completing for our second step the
client will request a challenge from the
server we will use the fetch API to make
a request to this endpoint that doesn't
exist yet it will be a post request
without anybody content then we will
return whatever response we get back
from the request now let's go and add
this login public key Challenge and
point to the routes file we're adding a
new post route Handler that calls the
get Challenge from function from the off
controller this action doesn't exist yet
so we can head into the off controller
and add it it will take in an instance
of the challenge store and it will
return a middle middleware function in
the body of the middleware function we
will use the challenge method to create
a new challenge if there is an error we
will fall through to the next middleware
on the stack if the challenge was
created successfully we will send it
back in the response body now we can
head back to our assertion login script
and work on the third step this is the
step where we get the users existing
Pass Key and use the sign challenge to
authenticate on the server it will be in
an async function that will receive a
challenge then it will use the Navigator
credentials get function to get an
existing credential key pair from the
user this Navigator credentials get
function is also part of the web
authentication API from JavaScript at
the end of the function we will return
the credentials we found you may have
noticed that we passed in some options
that don't exist yet so we will need to
set them up within the options we have
indicated that we will be using
conditional mediation and our
credentials are of the type public key
within the public key option we will
send through the sign challenge now we
can move on to step four which will be
the step where we use the credentials to
log the user in we will create an async
function that takes in user credentials
this request will also require us to
send through some options but we will
build those in a separate function
shortly we will use the fetch API to
send a request to the login public key
endpoint which we created in Phase One
this will be a post request and we will
pass along the options object which we
have yet to create then we will return
the response now onto the options we'll
set up a new function to build these the
body will contain the user's credential
ID then the response field will contain
some details about the client data Json
authenticated data the signature and the
user's handle
we will also check if the public key
credential object can give us any
information about the type of
authenticator that was used to create
our credential key pair if we are able
to get this authenticator information we
will set that in the options to now we
can collapse these completed functions
and work on our final step for phase two
this step will redirect the user to the
appropriate page this redirect function
is exactly the same as the one we
implemented in phase one we have decided
to duplicate it here to keep each phase
separate and make the flow of
information easier if you have strong
feelings about dry code you may refactor
it as UC see fit our login flow is now
complete so let's head into the browser
to check it out when we click on the
email input field a little dialogue
appears to display our available pass
keys this is the conditional mediation
that we were checking for in our code
once we select our Pass Key we will be
prompted for verification we can scan
our fingerprint to verify and because
our passport check was successful we are
now back in our empty dashboard and our
login button still works this concludes
our implementation of phase 2 where we
use our Pass Key to log in and there you
have it in this tutorial we learned more
about the web authentication API by
implementing pass keys in an expressjs
app we also use Docker and Docker compos
to manage our nodejs installation a text
version of this tutorial can be found on
div rhino.com and a repo can be found on
my GitHub account I'll leave both links
in the description for this video If you
learned something new while building
this project please let me know in a
comment or like the video and subscribe
to my channel thank you for watching I
appreciate you